oh you
[Music]
can perfect
[Music]
yo what's up everybody i am thomas
dopaziolo i am here with marty o'neil
what the [ __ ] is up what's up guys
welcome back to another episode of the
dope as usual podcast whoa that's never
happened yeah we got to bring that back
up
it's a [ __ ] special episode
um guys this is dope as usual podcast
we're here to talk about life drugs
accomplishments problems and everything
in between today
very special guest you guys have been
asking since we [ __ ] started episode
one the legendary be real is here with
us today how you doing man thanks for
having me bro it's about time it's about
time i'm excited
i like that you brought your own we too
nobody nobody's ever prepared like that
i try to be uh prepared everywhere
that's i mean that's that's me literally
i was like i don't have enough time
justin you please start wrong [ __ ]
joints so i had this little rolling
joints i just no one's ever brought oh
no boo johnson he wrote spliffs though
so the guy you were talking to
originally eitan the one everyone [ __ ]
his name up yeah yes they [ __ ] your name
about they time we know this um
he's our in-house
resident joint roller so like he's the
one
you know before we did the podcast and
this we do it five days a week um he'll
roll up to about 16 to 20 joints
every day like right before the podcast
because we're we're all smoking like
four or five each and then if we got a
guest we have their lot and stuff like
that so he's the one that puts him every
day every day well we don't do weekends
we do monday through friday still shout
out to him
we're rolling our own on the weekends
but yeah eitan rolls our our podcast
joints over there he's our in-house
roller coaster he's not the champ though
we got we got an in-house champ who's
the champ his name is pedro right
he also does like um
photography and video work for for be
real tv and all that stuff everybody's
sort of uh you know they wear different
hats and whatnot
but pedro you know when we used to um do
these in-house rolling competitions
pedro was the champ and him and etan are
always in competition on who rolls the
best i know eight times some pretty good
[ __ ] yeah this is rolled by eitan
right here all right that looks like a
damn turtle bro so that's good shout out
to you that [ __ ] looks perfect yeah we
call this a soft six right here but the
soft sticks
so your guys is the fantasy factor for
wheat out there you know um yeah it's
like the university when they you know
when they first you know like i was
telling you i've been doing the the the
the live streaming broadcasting whatever
for about 12 years now right
and
when everybody came to you know work
with us in the beginning
you know there was a couple of us that
were you know
certified smokers for a long time like
myself and
uh my boy jay turner rest in peace and a
few others that that are still around
you know that we've been smoking a long
time so
people coming into our circle had to
build up tolerance to actually be around
and uh it's funny because now everybody
that that works in our building no one's
a non-smoker they're all pretty much
beast-like when it comes to smoking
and uh you know just because
i just kept
it's the job putting weed on the table
rolling exactly that was in the
prerequisite roll it what do you do it
roll it it's not bad i mean when he had
a resistance she smoked no
she can't mind if i box the [ __ ] boom
i don't i just feel bad i know because
you had to think about when you're a kid
and you're smoking oh my god i smoked a
whole blunt to myself today holy [ __ ]
and now you're like when you hear an
adult say that and i passed out i hit
the weed twice like
yeah [ __ ] like you especially from being
from the east coast
yeah it's a trip man it is a trip you
know when you see the seniors
that that come to uh
you know the dispensary
you know because of the dr green thumb
dispensaries and whatnot and and on days
i'll go in and uh just be around
do the handshakes with people and you
know making sure
people are happy and whatnot
and uh i'll see seniors come in and
they're [ __ ] you know buying their
weed and
it's like something you never thought
before yeah you know like because
they're the people you thought were like
oh [ __ ] the weed you know you shouldn't
be smoking it and blah blah blah but
[ __ ] you see
a whole lot of seniors going up they're
buying strong [ __ ] weed too not
not some [ __ ] that you know that
you would think that that
because of some of the prescription
drugs that they take
you know that um
they wouldn't even be in there but
that's why they're in there they don't
want to take those prescription drugs
and they want to take this [ __ ] as an
alternative
and so they they take the strongest [ __ ]
from us from some of the concentrates
edibles and even like endica
you know dominant flowers it's amazing
to see that because when you look at a
senior you're like yeah they can't have
that's where i want to be when i'm older
they can [ __ ] hang
that's awesome yeah where's your where
are your shops at um we have um
we have six right now there's there's
[ __ ] six yeah there's three no
there's six there's um
there's
sacramento
san francisco cathedral city
los angeles uh silmar which is about to
reopen we had a couple of issues down
there that we had to shut down
temporarily but that's about to come
back online in the next few weeks or so
and uh the newest one which is in san
diego and
we're about to uh start opening up
outside of california oh wow along with
some some other california locations
where like you know
popping them up yeah that's such a
end goal there's so much room for
opportunity that we've been talking
about in cities like buffalo and places
where it's about to roll out oh yeah
east coast like this i've seen it happen
in orange county over the past couple
years how the whole game has changed and
i'm just like man i want to get in on
this [ __ ] because i already know what's
going to happen the whole oh yeah for
those cities that are all based around
alcohol right now it's just going to
they're going to realize over the next
couple years and all these old people
are going to die off
you know that don't either
yes that's not
wrong a couple yeah i'm looking about 15
years from now what it could look like
for buffalo could bring back the whole
[ __ ] city oh yeah and there are
smokers out there there's a there's a
cannabis culture everywhere in the
united states
anywhere you go it's just some of it is
stomped out a little bit that they can't
really speak up because law enforcement
you know stomps down on their on their
[ __ ] neck but
there'll be a day where
they'll be as free as we are here in
california and you know colorado and
nevada and all that [ __ ] but
it takes time you know um you it's it's
really
convincing
the conservative and and the religious
minded voter
and thinker because they're they're the
ones that actually hold full
legalization back
because you know still like
behind the times and backwards thinking
we were just talking about this recently
and just brought this up and and once
politicians can convince those voters
that hey this is
this is right
and you know economically
your city your state
your county can benefit from this and we
can create
um programs from this that will help
the community
um that's
when you can convince them of that
um that that's when things will change
in terms of
you know federal federal laws and all
that [ __ ] and how it's different from
one state to another that that has
legalization
legislation and all that [ __ ] but
we'll see it we'll see the change for
sure i try to try to travel to any state
that's not legal i just feel i feel
targeted almost you don't have to you
know say because what's there nothing
like bad times yeah nothing i want is it
still a nightmarish headache as an
established owner like in my mind i
imagine like man that's something you
gotta dedicate your life to it's gonna
be like they're gonna always be [ __ ]
with you as in any businessman you know
there's the great parts and then there's
not so great [ __ ] and you know you have
to deal with both of them accordingly
and and just keep
your mind straight and not let the the
the [ __ ] that will frustrate you and
cause distress
um get to you you know because
it's really
you think about where we were
20 years ago with
as it related to
cannabis
legislation and
where we are now i mean we didn't have
[ __ ]
you still go to you know jail for it's a
great place a nice amount of time
because of cannabis
plays places like that still and still
like that and we're fortunate enough
fortunate enough to be in a place that
that is uh you know a little bit forward
thinking
and and uh have evolved and realized
that there's great things you can do
with this and it's not the drug that
they've tried to to build the propaganda
upon and say well this is like cocaine
and heroin and you know all that [ __ ] we
know that it's not
and the key
i think right now and the fact that we
got it like this is because other people
that don't smoke that they've never been
smokers
finally got it
that this [ __ ] is helpful
you know
medicinally economically and it's not
the drug that they painted it as you
know when they were doing the
anti-propaganda of course not yeah no no
i mean just go out i mean california is
different you go down and see your
billboards you know you go down the
freeway and see your billboards and it's
even five years ago i didn't think it
would be this fast yeah so it's
happening yeah it's happening you know
and
you know look there's always gonna be
people that are [ __ ] elated about it
like oh this is [ __ ] great
and there's gonna be people they're like
man [ __ ] that i liked it better this way
um
but you can't have it both ways it's got
to be one or the other and for me i'd
rather have it legal so that i know that
my
my my homies and my family and myself
and just anybody
is not going to go to jail for [ __ ]
cannabis i mean that's [ __ ]
ridiculous and the fact that
now you know we could create legitimate
businesses and create more jobs
and
create bigger revenue streams
for
you know for for [ __ ] in our country
when you think about it yes if this was
legalized federally nationally across
the board
the money that cannabis could make this
country crazy right numbers yeah amazon
numbers easily it's probably more it's
the number one cash crop and it always
has been and it's still to this day
whether it's black market or
you know white market as they call it or
whatever the [ __ ] market
we know this and so i i think it's just
how you deliver the messaging to the
people that
might be reluctant to put cannabis as
you know something legal out there
it's the messaging and showing the other
things that that can be done with it
that's good
you know just some have focused on the
money as opposed to showing the other
things that you can do that's good
unfortunately 100 because i see you said
the money is what's going to make these
people change right because that's what
they [ __ ] they get they care about
because i've seen
500 videos of kids having seizures cbd
oil they stop right i didn't convince
anybody right the money is what's going
to convince people yeah like the fact
that you you had that
type of footage out there showing that
these kids with epilepsy
um
taking
you know the full
spectrum um
as as uh
as their
you know as opposed to something over
the counter or whatever the doctors are
going to prescribe in terms of
prescription pills and [ __ ] like that
it it it showed how it it took down
those seizures to a minimum to to zero
zero and the fact that they didn't make
that a bigger story that's like crazy
and that's weapon yeah that's that goes
to show you it's about the money it's
not
what good can be done from it because
here's the thing right it's it's
it's it's the same thing as there's no
money in it you know in a cure for
cancer
there's no money in it
initial there's today money but after
today money and you've sold everybody
the cure
you've lost
everything else after that and they
don't ever want to lose that so they're
not trying to cure anybody so anything
that's
so anything that's trying to cure
somebody or they could be beneficial
in this way they're not trying to make
make that kind of light of it but if you
show the type of money this [ __ ]
makes for any corporation
that they could invest in
all about it yep that's why things are
changing yeah that's
it's sad to say it's sad to say you know
i know he knows yeah because the
corporate money's coming in cannabis in
um 23.
they're already lined up now but they
they have to wait till 23.
really yeah so why why is that
i believe it was something to do with
the legislation at least here in
california you know when it became legal
there was a certain point that
they had to
it was keeping corporate businesses out
of out of cannabis so that they couldn't
run a monopoly
or something right exactly what's going
on
and it gives time for you know
independent companies to build
their brand and get it don't [ __ ] about
that at all basically they're giving you
a head start before the tidal wave comes
and washes your ass out and whoever
built the best structure and foundation
that can survive this tidal wave that's
coming
then you could do business and you'll
probably be doing all right but
everybody else they're gonna [ __ ]
have to sell their licenses sell their
retail sell this that
when you think about it this is what's
being done now it's it's it's not coming
it's being done now because when you
think about the taxation that we deal
with here in california it's unfucking
heard of
oh my friends from pittsburgh i told the
taxes what the [ __ ] did you say exactly
it's it's it's the it's the it's the
highest taxed industry in california
practically if n it probably is
and
how the [ __ ] is that
when did that happen you know what i
mean listen
they they left us up and running
as an essential business
so you think about that right the kind
of money they make from cannabis that yo
we cannot shut this down this is the
[ __ ] that's keeping our [ __ ] county
our city our
you know delivering trucks we're running
every day early pandemic and orange
county and we don't need people losing
their [ __ ] yes we don't want to lose
their money and lose their [ __ ]
dude i mean it just goes to show that
it's all only about money it doesn't
matter well it's everybody
it's it's unfucking real for me
it happened you know as a kid
you're getting hiding your ten sack
running away and to seeing these fools
make billions of dollars off of it is oh
yeah unreal and tell me if you agree
i feel like you said the tidal waves
coming i think that these companies
what happened to the boutique grower
guys what happened to all those little
companies 2014-15 bought up thank you
i said it they're they're going hey
who's doing good no keep the name but we
just own you now it's like when pepsi
starts buying everything yeah that's
exactly the the mentality is is let me
get this guy's ip get his knowledge let
me make him work for me it used to be
his now it's ours
we're going to keep him on the payroll
though because we don't know what he
knows on how to keep this running we can
just invest in it and make it bigger but
we're going to give him a smaller piece
yep but it's more money he's ever made
in his life so he's happy yes and and
you know to somebody who ain't never had
[ __ ]
that's a that's a great deal for them
the deal they want their life you know
but then when they look back you know
and they've been working for this
company for like 10 years and they
realize [ __ ] i help build this and i get
peanuts
in comparison it's like a shitty record
deal but that's the choice you made you
allowed that choice
yeah to to happen to be in front of you
and you signed off on it and that's you
know people got to know their their [ __ ]
so that they don't sign their life away
from for peanuts you know what i mean
because it's ip they didn't have till
you gave it to them there's a reason
they're paying you so much money right
because you're the [ __ ] man you're
knowledgeable you're the guy that's why
you know and and they're they
they don't necessarily want to do
business with the kind of cultivators
that know business
these guys know too much [ __ ] them we
can't
we can't run it on them we can't uh
there's no wiggle room here
you know they're not going to give more
than this because they know so let's
just move on
and they'll find someone another one
that you know is is talented but less
business savvy and just take advantage
of that that person sounds like the
music industry [ __ ] yeah it is that's
exactly what it is you know it's it's
the same in any of these industries it's
that same mentality
if you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
doing [ __ ] you're [ __ ] if you got an
idea they might [ __ ] with you for a time
um
or they might just let you do your thing
and be like you know what
we're gonna try this over here cause you
know he's gonna be a problem he knows
too much
when you know too much you're a problem
obviously
yeah and that's reality that is truly
um so i just want to switch it up a
little bit i uh
i'm when i was playing i always plan
these videos for each guest and
i think about what do i want to ask what
do i and then i think if i was a super
big cyber still fan or if i was a super
big b real fan what would i ask if i had
the opportunity so i got a couple and i
kind of want to um
get into some background because even i
don't know gotcha where are we raised
here in los angeles yeah yeah what part
well you know i moved around a lot as a
kid but um
you know
originally it was east l.a
around that area and uh
but we moved around a lot so i
eventually ended up on the lower east
side towards
southgate maywood bell
area huntington park
and that's where i met sandog and them
in in uh southgate
but i was in that general area i went
from being in east l.a montebello
monterey park around there
over to
around southgate and all that
and uh so yeah i was i was pretty much
east side
kid
you know for a long time
and uh
you know
when i met send dog that's when i got
into the music deep that was that was my
next question yeah you know i was i was
into the to the to the b boy [ __ ] the
popping yeah aspect of hip-hop and all
that stuff
you know we were all fans of hip-hop
before before i was a hip-hop fan though
i was listening to a bunch of different
[ __ ]
growing up on the east side you know
it's it's like uh girl listening to
oldies like the doo-wop the [ __ ] from
the 50s
60s like anthony and [ __ ] like right all
this right and uh you know so that i got
from my older brothers and older sisters
right and the [ __ ] that i would listen
to that my mother was that my mother was
listening to she would be listening to
like class what we consider classic rock
now like the beatles and [ __ ] oh that
yeah like
what would that be called uh
i'm asking the right person but uh
yeah
i'm sorry it's called classic yeah it's
classic rock too you know it's it's it's
classic classic rock classic yes because
rock them like uh
let's have a pink floyd well that's
classic rock too that that that would be
considered classic rock the next
generation that's the second generation
of it i would say right so you know
mom's listening to the beatles and all
that type of [ __ ] along with all the
salsa music and you know
like all the spanish [ __ ]
and my father he liked to do walk the
old [ __ ] you know stuff in the 50s and
and
[ __ ] like that so i grew up listening to
a lot of stuff but mainly i was
listening to a lot of you know rock and
metal yeah yeah no [ __ ] yeah and then uh
when i moved over to uh southgate
and i started hanging it with hanging
with these cats over there i started
listening to hop we were listening to
kday 1580k day
and you would hear
the first drops of hip-hop coming
through that am station this is before
fm was playing any
any uh hip-hop out here in in cali
and you know run dmc caught my ear
because their [ __ ] you know one of the
first things i heard was um what was it
um
sucker mc's or here we go one of those
two and then eventually at rock box or
kings of rock or something like that
along them lines and run dmc sort of
reeled me into hip hop from there
because
i stopped listening to rock and metal
after oh here i run dmc i was [ __ ]
hooked
and then that's what eventually got me
into the popping and breaking it of the
hip-hop culture cause i wasn't into you
know getting on the mic yet or any of
that stuff that came later but
yeah that [ __ ] initially got me but that
was you know
i was hanging with these dudes who
introduced me to mellow mayonnaise which
was send dog's brother
mellow man ace he was also a b-boy you
know he was in the break dance and [ __ ]
like that and that's how we knew julio g
as well
and uh
they were making the transition from
popping and breaking on to
you know getting on the mic and getting
on the turntables julio was getting on
the turntables
sen and sen and melo were now getting on
the microphone
and i was writing poems then but i
wasn't writing raps i didn't know how to
do that [ __ ] and melo sort of
crossed me over on to writing poetry
into
rap [ __ ] and that's how i got from you
know
rocking with the popping and the b-boy
and [ __ ] into now on the mic it was them
you know bringing me over into that [ __ ]
i saw what they were doing i said [ __ ]
it i'm gonna do what they were doing
what age
they they they were older than me
they're older than me by a few years so
they were probably
18 in 19 or 18 and 20 something like
this and so you're in high school so i'm
like 15 16 years old at this point
because it's been that much longer that
it popped off though right yeah no it
was
yeah i mean i was always the young buck
in the circle yeah
i was always trying to hang with the
older kids do doing bad [ __ ]
here man
um
yeah
um yeah it was uh
it was quite a time though the ride like
learning you know the culture and and
living the culture of hip-hop at the
time you know we thought we were all
about it and
when we looked at it we actually were
you know we we
were living all those steps up to when
we decided that hey this is our this is
our path right here it's authenticity
like you weren't trying to be like the
rappers you just were like yes
that was happening in your day yeah
uh i'm gonna
i told uh i have my manufacturer do all
my push tree stuff they also do a lot of
your homey wonder bread stuff wonder
break yeah that's my boy oh they do you
do your packaging you talk about evan
yeah yeah yeah oh so that's what i'm
talking about uh the manager there one
of the uh
printing managers he watches our show
and we mentioned that you're going to be
on and he came up to me so make sure you
write this down and ask him just say it
oh [ __ ] he goes ask him does he remember
southgate liberty middle school oh yeah
okay he's absolutely i was a little kid
always playing basketball in my hands
yeah and then i remember you know be
real and everybody hanging out you know
just
just
yeah so shout out to rahul he wanted me
to ask that from the absolute stuff
absolutely correct um so
so
cypress hill is derived from the street
that um senddog lived on which was
cypress avenue in southgate
we got the hill from from this movie
called wild style there was a
breakdancing one right um there was a
rapper named ramel z
and in one song he shouts out he shout
outs a place called cypress hill
and we're like oh [ __ ]
that's what we should call ourselves
we're cyber savvy let's just throw the
hill down
and we were big fans of ram lz so we
thought [ __ ] yeah that's the move and so
that's where the [ __ ] cypress hill
came from but as cyprus avenue
um and southgate
all you know a lot of kids knew each
other especially the ones who liked to
play sports so
when it was football season blocks would
challenge other blocks hey let's go down
to southgate park and run a game
you know what i mean um and
sometimes we as as the cypress block
would be playing like two blocks at the
same [ __ ] time but they we were
sought out like in the neighborhood
[ __ ] fun they always wanted to take
our heads off but
we always hammered them tag football in
the street no [ __ ] tackle football on
in the park like oh in the past
no no helmets nothing just going for it
right
and so
foot basketball season
you know they they wouldn't allow us to
be at cyprus
um southgate high school playing playing
on the courts
because you know some of us weren't
students there
and they just did not allow that so we
had to take it down we had to sneak into
[ __ ] liberty
liberty middle school
jump defenses there because they didn't
really have security there so
and they knew all the neighborhood kids
went and ran games down there so we
[ __ ] ran games down there you know
and we would ball it the [ __ ] up now
these aren't like um
you know the the 10 foot rims or
whatever
so we're dunking on each other yeah
so we're dunking on each other like
we're pro-styling it
and so that made the game actually
really fun i mean yeah we would we would
run down to southgate high now and then
like on the weekends and run games with
[ __ ] but a lot of times we'd be
over there at the middle school running
the slam dunk games because
none of us had the real hops you always
feel cool as [ __ ] when you're above the
rim coming down
there yeah none of us had the real hops
so we could you know what i mean that's
cool
i would do the same [ __ ] yeah those are
fun times though man you know because we
we'd be playing [ __ ] game after game
after game there and
you know you you ran the games until
someone beat you
oh no i never played like that yeah no
we that's
that's how we ran you're a basketball
player i've never done it like no that's
how we ran it's crazy yeah our squad
used to run games i mean um um uh t-funk
from funk dubious was on the squad with
us because we knew him before funk
dubious was even a group
and so you know he pl he was a point
guard for southgate high school when he
went to school
and uh so he was on our squad and we
haven't yet well he was one of us so
he had skills we used to run
[ __ ] but sometimes we got round
two though you know that's the nature of
it
can't beat can't win them all right but
yeah we used to run all the time
no one liked guardian send dog
[ __ ] big well
yeah
he's just a rough house and they didn't
like really yeah and they didn't like
when he guarded them
because you know we there's no referees
there
you know
you got to be sturdy and said dog would
put it on [ __ ] many elbows and
[ __ ] across the teeth yeah he didn't no
one liked playing against sand dog like
if him and i were ever on separate teams
man i hated playing against him like
that because
he's a roughhouse player
that's how i learned how to play like
watching him roughhouse [ __ ]
myself okay that's like shag
oh man yeah
um
well that's basically where i was
leading into
you started doing cyprusil for real
around 16.
uh i i would say for me it was about
probably 18. oh really yeah because i
was gang banging for a time like heavy
you know oh at 15ish yeah like in
between
15 and in
yeah 17 18. something like that i i
would say
before you were into hip-hop you were
gang-banging well
so simultaneously it was kind of
simultaneous right you know i was in the
to the to the popping and breaking got
into the rapping
and for a while like i lost touch with
these guys and i was just straight up on
the street gang banging with
a straight up gang bang yeah i was uh
from uh
from a blood gang
um 89 l.a 89th street family swan um and
so that's that's who i was running with
while they were like still working on
the music they took the hobby into
something a little bit more serious
where i was in it when it was we were
just a hobby you know we weren't making
demos we were just sort of
you know living hip hop as a fan and
appreciating the [ __ ] but i went off and
you know i started slanging and i'm
doing all these other shits we're
selling weed and [ __ ] well crack weed oh
okay so this is 1985 then 85 86.
so that was heavy right there yes yeah
and i was young doing this [ __ ] so
you know they're they're like uh getting
deeper into the music while i'm getting
deeper into the gang [ __ ]
and they kept trying to bring me back
because they knew i i had something with
writing
my writing was pretty good but you know
my delivery wasn't that great but my
writing was good so
they were looking at trying to look out
for me like let's get them off the
street we'll just have them come right
for us and
all you know this this type of [ __ ]
right so and you're the youngest one and
i'm the youngest one so they kept coming
back to get me and i think it took them
like three four times before i was like
you know what [ __ ] it i'll try it
because i was i was like wrapped in it
you know i was really wrapped in it
because you know i i kept telling them i
don't want to do this rap [ __ ] i gonna
get paid off this [ __ ] you crazy
you know indoctrinated right like
straight up um so
why are you jumping in gangs when you
have this is it was your family in that
involved in this well yeah to a degree
but on a way different side they're not
not on this on on where i went
and started banging with bloods and
stuff like that totally different side
if you could relate what i'm saying you
know um that's because i'm saying i'm
mexican
what it was yes 80s it was very hard for
me
it was very hard for me to
you know to fight people all the time
man that's what i'm hearing and i had to
prove myself you know i'm saying but
um i did what i had to do and i you know
i was there and uh you know fortunately
i had
the homies in send dog mugs and mellow
and there was other homies from
southgate that
they'd always had my back like childhood
homies and [ __ ] like that but those
three guys they were like
let's go get lou let's
try to get him riding cuz
we already know what he's doing over
there that [ __ ] ain't leading him
nowhere i didn't see it i was just you
know earning whatever stripes i was
learning and you know living that
[ __ ] life and i went to it it wasn't
like it
it was like uh that i didn't have no
choice i [ __ ] went to it you know
what i'm saying
um because that my family
throughout has
been connected with this or that at some
point
so it just called naturally to me
and uh you know i was living it and
somehow they convinced me to come to the
studio and write some [ __ ] from mello
on his first album which was river
cubanos and i think a song called
tacapella
and when i did those i was in the studio
a delicious vinyl with those guys
you know um a lot of the time when they
were making mello's first album
so i started seeing you know like tone
low coming through i started seeing
young mc coming through and
some of the other folks that were
assigned to delicious vinyl and then
other folks that were in the industry
that were
you know p you know movers and shakers
coming through delicious vinyl and i'm
like right there like oh [ __ ]
so i you know at that point i start like
feeling like man
i i kind of like being in the studio
around this [ __ ] and
that's when i stopped wanting to be on
the street corner less
you know i mean of course and then i
made it and then i made a choice i was
like you know what it's this or that i
can't bring this into this so i told my
close circle of homies
that hey i'm going off to do this
straight up
we cool and then we're like go do that
[ __ ]
and uh that was that and nice you know
been
doing it ever since and and it was the
chance that those three dudes took on me
to write these two [ __ ] songs
because had that not happened there's no
cypress hill ever
what a small little
there's a window you know yeah it was a
small opportunity because every time
they asked they care less man they're
like this [ __ ] just
every [ __ ] time yeah and they just
kept going and they were that's great
consistent they were persistent because
i i turned them down like at least three
to four times and my mother had paid
them one time to
just snatch me up in a van and [ __ ]
get me out of there
my mother was like on some different
[ __ ]
you know she used to slang different
kind of packs like on yeah you know
weed and other [ __ ] like she was oh when
you were younger
yeah even yeah pretty much
so
she had money you were around this your
whole life i was around in my whole life
uh you know and were your brothers and
sisters in this [ __ ] too
uh they probably knew about it i don't
know if they were in it but you know are
you the youngest
one of the youngest okay so
you know my mom she had she had money so
she you know she was like trying to
bribe the homies into like and get him
out of there
and you know they would they didn't want
to [ __ ] around because they knew the
[ __ ] i was hanging with at that
time
they see some funky [ __ ] they're
blasting first
you know so they're like well we gotta
we can't kidnap him but we kill him
he gotta choose this [ __ ] we can't just
pull him out we'll get killed you know
and uh but fortunately they were able to
to
convince me like you know what do you
got to lose man just try this [ __ ] if
you don't like it [ __ ] it you can go
back to the street
and i was like you know what you're
right [ __ ] it let me let me try and i've
been stubborn for for
this whole time i was being an [ __ ]
about it you know like man [ __ ] off with
that [ __ ]
but they they hung in there with me and
i felt like you know all right [ __ ] it
if they if they if they felt this
heavy about taking a chance on me i'm
gonna try it yeah and then after after
that i chose up and i said i'm not gonna
make these guys look bad and bring this
[ __ ] over here
so i'm gonna leave this behind and just
fully one
million percent commit to this [ __ ]
right here
oh musa you're 18 years old
yeah everybody convinces you that you
have it
you start cyber seal
what do you guys do you're just sitting
around going hey let's make an album
because back then you can't just go hey
post that on our instagram man well you
know for a while it was it was working
with melo and then trying to figure out
what to do you know because send dog was
with mello for a while and and me and
mugs were working on [ __ ] trying to
figure it out
and then uh
as things happened
um
melo lets go of senddog as his hype man
and whatever
and so now senddog's got
more time to try to develop this thing
with me him and mugs
and we start working on demos
and uh
it took a minute before we got we got
some [ __ ] that we actually liked
or loved rather we liked the first
couple of you know things that we did
but it wasn't like that
would we buy this
right if you're not yourself would i
actively go hey this is time yes would i
[ __ ] with this that's how i think of
when i design everything i do right
exactly this question i asked myself and
if if if you can't answer that or the
question is now and [ __ ] they
start over [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying
and and you know we had that point and i
think every band or or group or artist
does you know like where you're like
listen back and be like yeah you know
what this is cool but it's not that [ __ ]
that's like what muggs's
response was when it was it was cool
but it wasn't what it was gonna take to
get it over like you know hey what do
you think of this ah it's cool
but it ain't that [ __ ]
and you know
putting egos aside you have to have that
mentality
right so we were always like if if it
ain't if it doesn't move you
keep pushing you know
you could be creative
in in different ways and and and grab
something else out of something that you
thought would work but didn't
you know and so
so the first demos that happened they
were cool i wasn't using my my voice
that you would eventually hear on the
first album i was using this voice here
and
the rap style was cool the words were
cool but the voice wasn't cutting
through none of that [ __ ] and i remember
muggs had to go to um he went to new
york to start working on some of the
[ __ ] he wanted to absorb the flavor he
wanted to go back home
and absorb the flavor and and get
inspired by being out there on the east
coast the mecca you know what i'm saying
and uh when he he got to the airport the
cats that were picking him up were
bringing the car around
and he lost sight of the bag that
all his floppy disks were in that he
would use for the um sb 1200 that he was
using
and someone snatched the bag so
the the year of work we had done in
terms of the music
was all gone
oh [ __ ] it would mean that he had to go
back and resample and reprogram
everything
so we had to start from [ __ ] scratch
so somebody out there has the original
cyber syllabus
whether they know it or not
they have the original demos before i
flip my voice
right
and
mug still has like a couple of um
cassette tapes with
with some of those original songs and
beats but
what we lost was dope as [ __ ] let me
just say that off top it was dope as
[ __ ] but
it wasn't [ __ ] with anything that we
eventually made on that first album
like you know some artists will come and
say oh man i wish we had that one
because that one was the
now it made mugs work harder dig deeper
he actually now had more experience on
putting together tracks because he had
spent that [ __ ] year doing these ones
and getting to know the the sb 1200 as
as he's going
um it gave him more experience to create
that second run of demos which
eventually became the album
you know i mean so it was like a
blessing and disguise that [ __ ]
happening you know what i mean exactly i
love that
yeah no none of us looked down on it we
were just like [ __ ] it let's just all
right [ __ ] words in the moment it's like
the world is over but then you look back
like goddamn that was a blessing i know
he was stressed when when he realized
that he was probably pissed the [ __ ] off
because he got got he got a pretty ill
temper
so i know he
was [ __ ] hot
but
in the end you know sam and i were just
like whatever let's just [ __ ] make
some new [ __ ] whatever or if you want to
recreate this [ __ ] whatever we let's go
because by that time we had
a momentum on a momentum on how you
write songs we had an idea and a
momentum right like the idea of
verse
chorus break
verse chorus or
you know verse chorus verse
out you know we didn't we didn't want to
do any one thing but we knew that this
is how you put together songs and you're
learning as you're going along and we're
learning as we're going along because
there's no school for this [ __ ] i guess
that's literally at someone's house or a
studio yeah
learning how to make albums someone had
to teach a rapper how to write a song
because before a rapper would just come
and write a bunch of words and there was
no chorus there was no catchy part it's
just a rap on a beat
and you you know you have to have
structure
if you don't have that someone has to
teach it to you and if you never learn
it
you're [ __ ] but if you could learn it
as you're going along you see
examples of what other [ __ ] are
doing and you implement that in your
writing if you're the one doing the
writing
and you learn how to write songs
some become great at it some
not so much but
you know um
if there was a [ __ ] songwriting
school you would
you would see how many more talented
writers there are
than we see today gotcha there's some
bad [ __ ] out there they just
you know
you gotta find them
and there's really no school for it
still i mean there i would imagine there
are places that
that give you the game now but like
unless you're searching that out
it's it's just you know
i understand it's it's it's sort of lost
in translation you know there's more i
know marty gets this way more than i do
because marty actually is a musician so
i know you understand that way more than
i do yeah i'm not not a musician but
i've definitely taught myself to comp
bars and write instructional songs and
go into the studio and [ __ ] for sure
right because unless you go to school
for that you don't know that [ __ ]
as a rapper right unless you went to a
school of performing arts or you took
some sort of music class to know
measures and bars and all this [ __ ]
um there's a formula it's definitely not
just all your really good rhyming right
it doesn't matter if it doesn't [ __ ]
work oh yeah and beyond that it's rhyme
combinations and like you know how you
then like how do you structure it from
there like i was telling him i used to
carry around sticky pads and write down
all these little thoughts on these
sticky pads and then just look at them
all and kind of start arranging them and
piecing them together and [ __ ] yeah
that's thoughts just come about randomly
yeah
i mean you know that's that's how it is
but
it's cool because people now have so
much
in front of them to see
you know how it's done
yeah and with just youtube alone yeah
yeah i mean just that side with
technology it made fans
become
artists much quicker
you know than a person that you know was
a fan of of of this person had musical
abilities but never sought it out
because they can't
they can't see themselves being big like
the person that they idolize and stuff
like that those days are over
right it's like i could totally be like
this [ __ ] if someone just
notices me yeah and
that's crazy area it's not so black and
white yeah it's easy to blow up but it's
harder to stay relevant now right if
you're starting right yeah because it's
like
but you got to figure out how you stay
relevant throughout time if you want to
have the long run yeah it's like you
can't you cannot write a trend anymore
that's one thing you will die there's
been very few people that have had to
run like you and become such an
entrepreneur and just crossed all over
the place and looked into the future
into digital media and was ahead of it
looked into weed like
so many different things we could i mean
touch on with that
you know we were we were fortunate to be
in the group of of artists that were
constantly campaigning and
and um being a part of the advocacy and
activism of legalization of cannabis
right um in hip-hop
we weren't necessarily the first
mentioning it but we were the first like
running up that flag of legalization and
being unapologetic for it
and
it made other artists look at that and
be like we want to do that too we're
gonna do that [ __ ] that we're because
we're about that same [ __ ]
like red and meth and then event you
know and snoop and
in the rest right they all thought the
same thing and we're like [ __ ] yeah
they're we're gonna run that [ __ ] too
[ __ ] that
and it made it
more okay yes you know it it it less
taboo
um hey [ __ ] snoop's talking about it red
and metz talking about a dress talking
about it these cypress dudes are talking
about [ __ ] why
[ __ ] that i'm doing it too
and it's weird how it's like a silly
thing for them like right ball weed is
funny like martha stewart but
he's always been like that what it is is
is is it made it okay and it made people
want to do the homework like why is
everybody talking about why is this a
jimmy kimmel yeah
yeah
totally it you know it made people more
um
intrigued about it and want to learn
more like why is this a thing now and
then it it rallied people to our side
beside that but behind that type of [ __ ]
right there you know like because people
that didn't necessarily smoke but maybe
they had family members that smoked or
maybe they had family members that had
some sort of ailment that this [ __ ]
could help they
instantly related and changed their
[ __ ] outlook and maybe they don't
smoke maybe they tried smoking one time
but it's not for them or they had a bad
experience so don't stay so they stay
away from it
but they still support it because they
know the benefits from it
you know how it helps people in the
medicinal realm
and you know whether they give a [ __ ]
about the economic part or not they
care about the human side of it
you know those folks that that you want
over like well [ __ ] if this helps
with this and that why isn't why isn't
it legal
and then it rallied it's corruption
and it rallied those folks to come in
with the folks that were like already in
the know
and get it passed in in certain states
and stuff which you guys were doing
yeah so you know um it was it was just
basically like the each one teach one
mentality those that don't don't put
them in the know and see what they do
yeah are they gonna put up or shut up
and and to people's credit they [ __ ]
put up
you know everywhere you know people were
tired of going to jail for cannabis or
their loved ones going to jail for
[ __ ] weed and
you know and then some
understood the value of what it could be
if we were able to have this legal or
recreational or medicinal sales on it
i mean
through the roof right like we were
talking about earlier it could fix an
entire state right and so you know
people that recognize that they're
always going to push for it and
low-key you got these politicians that
will will push against it
but
you know unbeknownst to everybody in the
[ __ ] world they're invested in it
there's like high-level republicans
invested in the cannabis industry right
now
that gave up their post
you know what i mean to to come invest
in the [ __ ] cannabis industry and
they're pulling other
you know um politicians
in with their money because they got the
[ __ ] big money they got the the
you know
hedge funds and the corporate funding
and stuff behind them i mean they're all
going to [ __ ] walk you know pat each
other's backs and
you know um wet each other's beaks
so you know low key yes they're doing
this [ __ ] when they can do it high key
believe me you'll see it yeah and that's
coming in 23
like we were saying before but
you know that's how that's how powerful
this industry is that it would make a
republican
um change their mind like that you know
like
hop off the job he was doing in the
senate or congress or whatever
and come right into this industry
and invest and just start raking in
dough
i mean that's powerful yes
well like we said money money all that
matters money changes your whole [ __ ]
ethics
um that is no lie
before i get too off topic
what was your guys's first show when you
sorry back to what we were saying what
was the first show you guys ever did
that you
went up and you guys alright this is an
actual show guys um
first show do you remember you know what
yeah i mean we had done
several like showcases
and showcases means like in front of a
yeah in front of like so if you wanted
to get signed to a company like
or whether it's a publishing company or
agency or management
firm or a record company you would
sometimes do these showcases
and
you know that was set up by whoever your
manager was at the time
and usually that wasn't going to stay
your manager that's just the person like
you know helping you get from step a to
b right
and so we would do a number of showcases
and stuff like that but
um once we got signed to sony and
roughhouse music oh no [ __ ] um
based off the music
now they wanted us to do promo shows and
we had been rehearsing and we had been
doing showcases for a long time so we
were like
you know
well we were prepared well enough
we're still nervous because we're in new
york and we're a west coast group
but people don't know that we're from
the west coast they assume
we're new yorkers and whatever really oh
yeah the cypress
cause cypress hill is a place in new
york oh
you know
it's in east new york i believe and um
so people thought we were from there and
we go up and we do this unorthodox style
hip-hop show
and
we want him you know fortunately they
[ __ ] with us because it was so
different
and even though i was still kind of
learning how to do my voice live at that
point and i wasn't really sounding close
to the record a lot of them hadn't even
known what the record was yet so this
because this was also but they liked
what they saw the energy from it so that
was like the first show show
um but to show cases we had done before
i mean
we had done a few [ __ ] memorable ones
there was one we did at
that place three palms off the 10 i
don't know what it's called now but it
used to be like a little club over there
and one once in a while it would do um
uh competitions music competitions right
like so you would get
amateur artists coming in and trying to
win the grand prize which was i don't
know maybe
five racks maybe right and so you would
have like rappers come
singing groups come solo artists come
and and all competing
in front of these judges who worked for
kjh k day and all these radios like yes
sex scouts you gotta pay to be in it
usually it's like thousands uh this this
one you didn't you didn't have to pay
you just had it
i think it was well no it was like a
hundred dollar entry fee right this is
how you pay the judges
fresh [ __ ]
so we had just written the song real
estate
and um
we're like [ __ ] let's do that one and
muggs brought his m his uh sb 1200 to
the to the place we didn't have no
turntables it was just that
and so me and sen were gonna wrap while
mugs was just cracking it off
on the [ __ ] mp on on the sb
and uh
there was this group there that was in
every showcase they were called what
were they called was it um
the idol kings
they were a christian rap group oh [ __ ]
they were tight they would clean up at
every single [ __ ] event like you know
they were always the favorites because
they were talking about god and they
were rapping and they weren't bad they
were pretty pretty decent rappers um so
but they would always clean it up
and then there was these dudes that were
like some new addition wannabes we
called them the tootsie rolls because
you know that's what their costumes look
like
and they came in there and then there
was us you know we came in there raw we
were unpolished you know they had all
performed did their [ __ ]
and uh
we said [ __ ] it we're just gonna go all
out [ __ ] them if they don't like us
our whole thing was let's just perform
in front of these [ __ ] and give
them a taste of
our brand of [ __ ] this is before we even
had our you know like
our deal deal
locked in
and so we do real estate
and we're
in people's faces like we're rapping in
the circle going up to people right in
their [ __ ] faces wrapping the song
like mad aggressive
and then send dog jumps on the middle of
the judges table and he starts wrapping
his verse
and he grabs his [ __ ] you know crotch
right there in front of the center judge
which was the lady judge
and he jumps off the table and the table
breaks in her lap
that [ __ ] was hilarious i feel like
there's one yeah and we felt like we won
we're like [ __ ] it if they
they could give it to the tootsie rolls
but that was the winning [ __ ] shot
right there because that's what
everybody remembered they didn't
remember
that the tootsie rolls won
the [ __ ] that they won that little five
racks they remembered that
these three [ __ ] came and were
rude as [ __ ] and broke the table on the
judge
and and you know that was the that was
the attitude that we would carry from
there because we were like it felt good
to us to not give a [ __ ]
and we carried that for the rest you
know um
we weren't that good then yet
but
but we felt that that was the energy
yeah that's the lane let's just do it
100 percent [ __ ] them if they don't like
us
and you know boom a lot of people aren't
like that a lot of people are trying to
have a sound that they know people like
or they're trying to go for a look or
whatever i love that just like this is
us [ __ ] you know for being hip-hop we
were very punk rock
in the sense that we we didn't give a
[ __ ]
you know we didn't care about people
seeing what we look like
we're very anti that you know like
because at the time everybody was
showing their faces and it's not hip-hop
to be like that yeah it's all about look
at me and how cool you are and [ __ ] yeah
no we were like nah don't show us we
don't want no one to see what what we
look like they could see that when we're
playing these [ __ ] songs but
right now we're going to be mysterious
back then it was better to be mysterious
now i mean there's something to it but
it's not the same out of sight out of
mind that's what it is now that's what
it is now yeah you can be like i love
this [ __ ] guy this rapper's so dope
three weeks later i go [ __ ] i forgot i
was listening to that [ __ ] for weeks
yeah i forget
yeah there's so much information
coming out before there was not so many
artists coming out you could you could
take a year or two to put out something
but now in the the thrust of these
thousands of artists that [ __ ]
come out every week
you know like if you don't put something
out
sooner than later you get lost in the
shuffle and then forgotten in that
[ __ ] shuffle
you know so you got to keep feeding your
[ __ ] base
you know and that's that's kind of
[ __ ] up as an artist that you got to
do it at that pace because that's not
art anymore it's not yeah it's actually
just like oh this is the job i have to
get done yeah like oh [ __ ] if i if i
don't put something out in a minute i'm
gonna fall the [ __ ] off they're gonna
forget about me
and that's how
it's built right now and it's
unfortunate because in hip-hop that's
hip-hop that's the only [ __ ]
that that
it boggles my mind that
um it's not as supportive as other
genres as as like the artists
let's just say you know after they've
had a 10 or 15 year run
right they look at all they're done
they they were done on their third
record
you know whereas in country they're
never done
no matter what nelson's 80. it don't
matter how many records this
[ __ ] put out i'm [ __ ] with
him
i am going
for the ride and you know with hip-hop
it's like yeah no i never really thought
about that for one you know they were
cool at this point but after that you
know i sort of
and that's that we're the only genre
that does that unfortunately they
thought about that you know and it's
[ __ ] up but that's the way that the
[ __ ] did put out this genre built it
so because they didn't have faith that
an artist could last that long so it's
like in out in out
and
the the [ __ ] up [ __ ] is when they hit
a lick and and this artist like puts out
a few
like albums that are banging they gotta
[ __ ] give them more money they're
obligated to that and they don't always
like that [ __ ] they'd always rather have
a one-off
really because it's cheaper to have the
one-off than it is to have to give this
[ __ ] eight albums the superstar
yeah you have to yeah you have to build
them up because contractually he's owed
that or she he or she is old that
and they got to spend more money
conor mcgregor on your [ __ ] hands and
he's taking [ __ ] off yes and
traditionally after like let's just say
you do hit a [ __ ] heavy run where you
got four or five platinum albums
the progression now is that you're going
to sell less
but because you've hit all your goals
and marks they owe you x amount of
dollars and they know that no matter how
much money and they invest in that
project especially in today's time
they're not going to get all that money
back
so now they're almost not rooting for
you yeah so they're almost like okay
let's just put this [ __ ] out onto the
next one
make you look bad yeah and it's it's
i mean it's the way they built it
unfortunately you know so you got to
make your run how you want it
after that
you know and somehow
stay relevant
and that's that's unfortunately the game
but you know hey there's [ __ ]
that are still having a great run after
all these years
you know they did their homework and
realized this is how we stay in the game
because yeah i mean diversity you were
like on the [ __ ] like be real tv and all
that like i mean i remember that when i
was just out of high school
on youtube i think
yeah you know i started that because i
was doing radio for a time
and i realized that the platform of
broadcast is powerful it's you know just
as powerful as
the music that we make that they play on
there but what happens if they're not
[ __ ] playing you you don't have a
platform now you do i mean there's so
many now yeah you could find one boom
and as long as you're pushing it
and guiding people to it though they'll
come to it they'll find it may not be
what you want or what you expect but
it can happen were you before myspace
with that or was it right around then
like no no no no no no no no
it had been out before tv came out okay
yeah well in my mind it was like so
early like hip hop game dot com it was
it was i believe 209
is when i started it and you know i
started it through stick m which was um
which was a um a streaming company that
was uh the the rival to ustream which
they were the bigger they were the
bigger company they had more
more user base their bandwidth was crazy
their technology was
way much more advanced right so we were
there and they they they sort of always
highlighted our live streams we'd get
like 150 to 250 000 stream um views
within like an hour's time back then
that's [ __ ] unreal and that was
unreal back then and you know whenever
they give you the feature page so we'd
be racking maybe a quarter of a million
views at the end of
of our broadcast and stuff like that so
we built be real tv on that
and and eventually you know brought it
to our own website which is be real dot
tv
hey what's up guys we just want to say
special shout out to one of our sponsors
this is liquid iv so for me personally
i've been using liquid iv for years if
you know me personally you know i have a
box of this in my medicine cabinet at
all times personally i use this whenever
i feel kind of sick whenever i know i'm
feeling like oh i got a scratchy throat
let me get hydrated i use these rosie
uses these we swear by them they have a
bunch of flavors lemon lime strawberry
watermelon strawberry is my go-to that's
the one i have a box of at home and no
it's not just when you don't feel good
this is for athletes this is the
ultimate hydration pack everybody taking
long hikes you this should be your best
friend and you probably already buy this
also liquid iv hydrates you two to three
times faster than just drinking water
alone so like i said it's not better
than water it just makes your water
better so right now you can walk into
your local walmart and buy a pack of it
awesome or you can help support the
podcast and click the link in the
description or click the link in the
pinned comments that's
liquidive.com and using code yola is 25
off but if you don't use the link and
you just go to liquidiv.com at checkout
use code yola that's 25 off it just yeah
christmas is coming man gift all your
athletic ass friends or and i'm not
saying this as a form of advertisement
but when i have been sh
hung over and i'm not saying go get
drunk and use liquid iv to help i'm not
saying that i am just saying it it helps
so before you get out of here go to
www.liquidiv.com like i said it'll be
linked in the description and the pin
comments use code yola that's yola at
checkout is 25 off
hey what's up guys we just want to say a
special shout out to one of our sponsors
this is manscaped as always go to
www.manscape.com forward slash yola and
that's 20 off plus free shipping the
mail grooming line for manscape this
year has been awesome if you guys have
been watching our podcast for a while
it's been months you've seen the
upgrades you've seen the upgrades from
the lawnmower from the 3.0 to the 4.0
and now introducing the body wash from
manscaped and the two-in-one conditioner
and shampoo so it's not just stuff for
your balls anymore all right it's for
your other head
i can peripherally see you guys go oh
[ __ ] here we go here we go as we always
say 2 million customers can't be wrong
and 4 million balls can't be wrong it's
the holiday season it's time to be
thankful christmas is coming up all
right the performance package it has
everything in there has the boxers the
ball toner and deodorant which is
hilarious it comes with the weed whacker
the lawnmower 4.0 and the travel kit and
as you already know the lawnmower the
new and improved lawnmower is skin safe
wireless rechargeable it's waterproof it
has a light on it no excuse whatsoever
to not be not gross so if you guys want
to take advantage of this discount it's
20 off plus free shipping all you gotta
do is go to manscape.com forward slash
yola like i said 20 off plus free
shipping you can't beat that as always
guys thank you so much for supporting
the brands to support us back to the
episode
and uh it but it started it started from
radio because i realized you know
whatever we wanted to to um
you know promote whether it was events
because i was throwing dr green thumb
events back in 98 97 oh no [ __ ] yeah um
i threw a birthday for the character
right
really
where was that character from it's just
i mean obviously i know what it means
but you just started [ __ ] around with
it you know
in writing the song you know we
eventually did a video because it became
a single and from that video i created
the character and then from the
character in the video i created my the
alter ego from it so i started throwing
events
under dr green thumb
and at the house of blues when it was
was in the height of its [ __ ] you're
throwing weed events at the house of
blues
sort of
you know and and yeah that's [ __ ]
awesome it was it was more music though
like you know it was a weird event but
it i made sure that i had enough artists
there hitting the stage that it felt
like a music event right so that you
know house of blues loved it because i
would pack this [ __ ] with people
and and uh they were all a drinking
crowd so they love that [ __ ] but
you know i threw i threw dr grantham
birthday because i felt like dr green
thumb the character needed a birthday
couldn't be the same as mine
right i love that
that's brandon and that was like the
first event i threw
for dr greentham it was a [ __ ] fake
birthday
and you know
who knew that
it would eventually become my my
cannabis bran in stores yeah actual
stores yeah it's kind of like push trees
how like it was a meme he's like you
know like yeah it was a joke
from a song
yeah i guess yeah yeah it was crazy
because we were we were working on the
album and that that was on and muggs
left the beat up overnight you know he
told us hey leave this up for because i
was getting in the studio in the
mornings 10 10 in the morning 9 10 in
the morning
and i heard that [ __ ] boom i was on it
immediately and you know me and my
partner who
is my partner in dr green thumbs now
which is kenji you know we were waiting
you know kenji that long oh yeah we've
known kenji and i have been
partners for
you know over 25 years what the [ __ ]
yeah i knew kenji when he was like 21 or
some [ __ ] like maybe 19 or something
like that he's one of the few people one
of the people i met at b-reel tv the
studio yeah i just [ __ ] love that
dude oh no yeah he's a cool [ __ ]
yeah you know we had a couple things in
common i mean he was the young buck
coming in through one of the homies one
of our mutual homies and and him and i
got got tight you know because i knew he
was like a connoisseur smoker not just a
smoker and so him and i sort of learned
to grow game
but he had more time to do it
so you know we'd grow in my garage
we grew some of our first og cuts in my
garage and and uh
in like i think it was late 97 something
like that
and that's where we started like the
whole og kush thing because it wasn't
called that when we got it
we started calling it that oh [ __ ] and
uh stop hold on stop yeah did you just
say you coined the turmoil you could
yeah i mean you can ask um you could ask
josh d damn
coolest [ __ ] ever he was the one
that gave
he was the one that gave someone in our
circle that cut
and that's the cut you were growing yeah
that one's still around today still
around today it's one of my favorite
[ __ ] yeah so all that ocean grown
[ __ ] that's not no it just meant
original kush oh gee kush so that's you
guys coined the term thank you for that
yeah because it was called something
different coming from florida it came
from florida
to um josh d in his circle
and a couple of our guys were
part of that circle
and we you know we had this other [ __ ]
called kush bubba so we were like you
know what let's call this og kush
thank you
thank you for your friends that's real
[ __ ] anyone who says different
tripping
damn dude put me on a [ __ ] lie
detector i'll show you dude that [ __ ]
helped me pay my rent for [ __ ] years
didn't it hey man that [ __ ] used to go
for eight eight racks a pack that was
2004 yeah okay right i remember that
then everybody started growing it and it
had to come just came out yeah and then
there was these are 85 like oh well the
ogs aren't as good is that what you're
telling me shitoji's were better they
were always better it was just the color
that made people go oh oh yeah 20 bucks
for a gram yeah that's all good yeah
like if someone in in that time at the
height well or the beginning of the
height of that weed of that o.g kush if
someone said they wanted the purple over
that they didn't know what the [ __ ] they
were they're a real smoker they weren't
real smokers they they were going by
the look of that this is purple it must
be better it must be stronger but they
weren't really
trusting the nose
you know what i mean and and really
looking
looking at those
those silver [ __ ] trichomes popping
off that [ __ ] and then the gas in
comparison to whatever that purple [ __ ]
was yes it was purple
it's good then it's cool yeah it's got
kind of a funky smell but it wasn't what
this [ __ ] was that's what i said to burn
my nose oh man yeah we were snobs with
that [ __ ] for a long time man if someone
was bringing anything other than og
we're like [ __ ] out of here with that
but here wait no we're gonna smoke our
[ __ ]
so you guys basically coined og kush
with kenji
you started growing in your spot before
dr green thumb was everything oh yeah
through your own birthday party for your
character yeah like what a story so
that's amazing we i wrote dr green thumb
as a tribute to our squad that was like
you know learning the grow game at that
time which was him and one of our other
homeboys named cap
and and uh
cap capper
okay we call him cap for short um and
and a few other dudes
you know and uh you know so it was like
a tribute song to the squad and i was
growing too i'd grow
i'd be growing in my backyard i'd grow
like [ __ ]
sometimes in the realm of 50 to 80
plants back there i don't know i don't
know how no one ratted me out or i
didn't get caught because you could
smell that [ __ ] down the block
um
he plants in a neighborhood
and everybody expected the [ __ ] out of
that neighborhood that they did
adam carolla lived down the street i
didn't even know he was down there
you know he told me about a year later
when i went to do love live he goes hey
be real check this out i think i lived
down the street from you i could smell
your house
i try marty actually works with adam
crowley yeah he's a good guy
yeah and uh you know i went to the man
house
is what they call it he gave me a tour
of the man house
um and uh yeah that was the block that
that i referenced
in uh the song dr grantham where i said
20 plants stinking up the whole
neighborhood it was
influenced by when we were growing in
that particular house that i was living
in
living down the street from adam
carolla's man crib bro i [ __ ] love
that you just broke that down
first time i ever heard cyprus hill i
was
four
and as
i just remember like what does he mean i
want to get high
shaco pass she is in the back seat in
the car seat and her mom and dad listen
to go what is it my dad is in the seat
i'm like he loves this what is this we
mean you want to get high one goes you
know we're going over the bumps you're
getting high and go low
huh yeah i like this yeah it's the first
thing i ever heard my mom's a huge cyber
sale fan so i've been to shows i think i
was 17 i went with her
to the 420 shows you should do frisco
yeah yeah still got the poster some of
the first 420 shows period were they
yeah no one was doing 420 shows when we
started oh in general in general yeah
yeah we and we did them in san francisco
because we figured you know in san
francisco they're sort of a little bit
more attuned into the politics of
capitalism
on smoking yes and a little bit more
lenient for sure
um we've always had a
deep connection with
you know the bay um
but we knew in terms of the politics of
cannabis and acceptance that they were a
little bit more open so when we decided
to do shows
on this date now that had been dubbed a
cannabis date
of 420
we were doing it when there was no shows
like no shows yeah people might have
celebrated here they're low-key you know
you're right what was the first 420
thing i did yeah and and
you know we started doing those shows in
um san francisco like on a you know
yearly basis it became an annual thing
and we stopped doing it the year that
wiz khalifa came into the market
because now he was doing his [ __ ] in an
arena
and we're like you know what we don't
wanna we don't wanna split the market we
don't want people to choose from us to
him we're gonna bail out of here
and we're gonna take our [ __ ] to denver
nobody was rocking 420 shows in denver
yet
so we were sort of the first jumping on
that date
and and creating events from it
and uh
the bay area was the first one we were
doing we were doing them at the fillmore
and the fillmore one i went to yeah and
at the the war field there's that spot
and then there was another spot that
that we did it at but mostly we did it
at the at the
at the fillmore
and we would take mushrooms
before we went on stage and just totally
tripped balls
oh [ __ ] do the 420 show just
you guys did well man you held it
together right
yeah you held it together for sure we
had our [ __ ] together and then two of
those and i didn't i couldn't be like
those guys are [ __ ] up those were some
of the best shows i remember we did two
420 shows in one one day we did um
we did uh we well
obviously we did the show at 4 20 p.m
i would do a night one yeah and then and
then we cleared the floor
and brought in a whole new
whole new audience sold it out twice in
one shot
and uh man i gotta tell you
that [ __ ] was hard because we played an
hour and 30 minutes both sets
we didn't shortchange nothing we like
played the hour 30 boom let the new
crowd in played the hour 30.
and then
yeah we were totally flying bro
you know i don't think maybe the first
show we didn't do mushrooms it was for
the nighttime show we did them like the
first first half we were just weeded up
but the second show someone i think it
was our boy trace and fran fran franny
dj fran delay bay
from vegas yeah i actually got his
lighter i think on that table over there
yeah that's that's the homie i've known
him for like 20 some odd years in in him
and his boy trace they used to do radio
together and we met them because we were
doing radio um
on the same station as them in the bay
and that's how we met them so when we'd
come to town for the 420 shows they
bring huge bags of [ __ ] bomb ass weed
but they would also bring like ounce
bags of mushrooms
and so they showed up for the second
show boom popped them
off we go
it was awesome damn
some people get staged right
remember in your [ __ ] lyrics after
that jesus christ two shows that's what
i'm trying to say like taking mushrooms
and doing the full [ __ ] set is unreal
to me oh yeah we that used to be a
regular thing we you know we looked at
always hearing about jimi hendrix doing
acid on stage and the doors doing peyote
and that's what inspired you to do it
yeah and the grateful dead and all that
[ __ ]
oh yeah did not know this man so we were
like you know we're up on it too we're
going to do what
they did because
they're tired it made them connect on a
different level and we were like we're
going to con
we were all boys already we
partied together we did like you know
aside from the music [ __ ] like we
actually
partied together we went wild and out
and all that [ __ ] right so we felt like
a lot of our a lot of our idols you know
in music went up there and as a
unit collectively they did certain
things
to have an experience together
so
we looked at that [ __ ] the same day same
way we did it with acid and we used it
yeah one unit we did it with acid and we
did it with uh mushrooms
and uh
yeah
it was interesting so how long was it
from when they rescued you off that
[ __ ] block to when you're rocking
these arenas and [ __ ] like how long did
that take probably about five five years
and you got the sony deal how long after
that yeah that that was it was probably
about five years yeah oh so yeah because
we start working on the first demos and
we got turned down by
several labels that didn't get it were
you pitching them
we weren't pitching them i wasn't [ __ ]
no i i didn't even talk in these
meetings you know what i mean because i
didn't know [ __ ] i was
learning how to write the songs
let alone
you know
this was my first time in any meetings
talking about music and like them asking
us what what is your music about what
does it stand for
you know all this [ __ ] and when you
don't know that and you don't have the
answers they're looking at you like hmm
you're going to take a lot of work
next you know what i'm saying yeah and
so you got to sort of if you're going to
meet with majors on the first run you
got to have a vision of what your [ __ ]
is back then anyway
so we were lucky enough to have interest
from joe the butcher who was in philly
which was roughhouse
they were distributed by sony a major
um they knew muggs from 783 so
homeboy knew muggs's um
potential
and he heard that mugs was working on
some new [ __ ] which was our [ __ ] so he
wanted to hear it and immediately he was
like i [ __ ] with this
uh you know how can how can we sign this
and at first we were you know talk
talking to some other folks you know our
homeboy funk and klein rest in pl piece
who was at a
who was at a record label called
hollywood basic they wanted to sign us
too but they were indecisive they kept
asking for demo after demo we had given
them like a half half an album of demos
and they were still like trying to like
well [ __ ]
you know is this it i mean it's dude
they have the songs whereas joe and his
group
chris schwartz and all those guys they
were like we want them
[ __ ] all that we heard enough from three
songs we won were they already a
legendary label at that point no so
fuji's all that not yet we we started it
off
we kicked it off and uh then crisscross
and then the fuji's
um
i believe that's that's how it went um
and uh
so
send dog was like you know what [ __ ]
that we're signing with joe
we've made too many demos for these
[ __ ] if we're gonna just keep
making demos i'm gonna go back and work
at kodak slang in boxes damn and so me
and mugs were like well i guess it's
[ __ ] roughhouse let's go
and you know again he already had mugs
already had a relationship with joe so
it made it easy you know and um
we went to work from there and uh
that was like at the three year mark of
us
working on the first demos into now
creating what was the new [ __ ] and so
the next two years were us
you know redoing some of those songs
and doing a couple of new ones and sort
of honing the [ __ ] in and then
eventually up to the point where we
release two years yeah nice so it was
like a five-year
you know ordeal from like starters
that's already they gave you that much
time to like put together your first
album or your whole what was going to be
they put out to the world well they
didn't know we had been working on it
before we even got the [ __ ] deal you
know what i mean so we came in slightly
ready it was just more fine-tuning than
anything but once we got the deal we
said [ __ ] it we're just gonna make some
new songs too was it the songs that
ended up blowing up did you already have
those or do those come about because of
the stuff they brought to the
table um
they always let us be creative we did
all our own [ __ ]
you know they just gave us the money to
be in the studio longer
and and the support and the resources to
make making this album an easier process
than what it was to make the demos for
it
so in my mind all the record deals in
the 90s were [ __ ] evil and they were
just screwing you over well they they
[ __ ] a lot of us over i mean you know
we didn't have the best deal but we
didn't have the worst deal either
you know um the thing is is that
when your lawyers
um
when they when they're of the mindset
that this
this genre might not last
you might not get the best deal they're
gonna [ __ ] be like well take what you
can right now because we don't know how
long and when you got a [ __ ] head like
that he's not really looking out for you
very exciting either yeah so you might
be stuck in a [ __ ] up deal or
you know
it could be a number of things and so
fortunately we were
you know smart enough to be paying
attention to people that had
you know been doing this that we were
connected to that you know we saw the
do's and don'ts
and
the the the power of good representation
as opposed to shitty representation so
we were always constantly
looking out for these things we learned
by example
from others that you know so we're going
in blind yeah so we we weren't going in
blind because we would see like how our
boys over here
were either doing it right or
mishandling their [ __ ] by not being on
their [ __ ]
and choosing up with the wrong people
not guiding them through this
things properly yeah
um i have a question i ask
athlete act it doesn't matter it's
anybody that has
you know a career as
a superstar
i guess you would say that all right i
was trying to find a better word
but i couldn't thank you a household
name household name anybody that's done
that do you have that um
moment i always say it i always say that
oh [ __ ] this is real moment
do you have that because i know if
you're four or five years ago selling
[ __ ] rocks to people
and then now you're like oh my sony shut
the [ __ ] up i feel weird
yeah and then you're like oh we got
signed what the [ __ ] was there a moment
in all of this or maybe it's your first
show or maybe your first tv appearance
is there a moment where you were by
yourself you're in your room you go
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know um
i i think it was
more so that when we got asked to do
like something like saturday night live
you know i mean like because other than
that that's what i mean i was sort of
just living it and not really thinking
about oh [ __ ]
you know i was just taking it as it as
it came for sure for sure as as opposed
to
absorbing it letting it all
you know once you see it yeah yeah the
name on a marquee or something like was
that the moment like oh
yeah that's our name yeah we were just
so so busy doing it then
recognizing it right
um but there was it so i should say
there's two right there there's there's
that moment when they asked us to to do
saturday night live because it's an
iconic show we grew up to it
and we know that a lot of legendary
[ __ ] touched that stage much
like when we did the whiskey that was a
place that we we absolutely needed to
play because
yes the whiskey of gogo yeah that was a
place we needed to play
for our state of mind like in being a
real group that
with the
with the mindset of
being around for a long time longevity
and making music and
being in the
the setting that our idols were yeah
right we had to do that [ __ ] and and so
things like that those those things
you'll always remember and hold true but
like this that was like what snl was
right like getting asked to do that
you're now in this elite club yep
and and it's forever
right
um so it was that
and getting banned from that was even
better because that from snl yes what do
you mean you got banned from the weapon
well because mugs blazed up a joint on
stage on yeah oh [ __ ] how do you i'm
surprised you don't notice i didn't know
that
yeah yeah i never saw that he said they
told us we can't smoke our weed but you
know what we ain't going out like that
and he [ __ ] likes to join
and you know boom awesome cut to
commercial no they didn't cut it they
they kept it playing and they ran it in
syndication
they still do as soon as the camera's
off like you guys can't [ __ ] come
back no
it was it was after oh okay it was
well [ __ ] this is how after it was you
know there's a after party after every
snl and they invite the artists and you
know all the staff and and uh the
writers and some of the performers
entertainers they go to these after
parties and hang out drink whatever and
we're back there hanging out smoking and
drinking with them like nothing and so
you know we assumed everybody had a
great time
and then we got the note
the very next day well nbc has banned
you from blah blah blah from saturday
night live this and that the other
and uh you know we were like cool [ __ ]
it because this is
this it's who we are we didn't get mad
about it it was like it's like
we
we you know we had the intention of of
this you know what i mean we knew what
was at stake because that wasn't
something muggs did without anyone no we
knew
he was gonna do that now where he did it
was misplaced but
we knew that this was the ultimate goal
was we were going to blaze up on tv that
day one way or another it was supposed
to be at the end
at the beginning yeah he did it at the
beginning we were gonna
we're gonna do like play the song like
normal and towards the end the very end
chorus of the song we were gonna start
disconnecting our turntables and
everything and just start smashing the
set
like you know like they like the who
like you know in metal and [ __ ] like
this because that's what we were doing
on tour we were totally smashing our
[ __ ] sets so we were gonna do this on
saturday night live and then at the end
we were gonna [ __ ] stand over the
heap and blaze our [ __ ] joints
like it was you know after sex right
and but it didn't go like that because
mugs [ __ ] lit joint first
and uh you know so it was what it was
but we got banned because you know
either way you guys are getting mad
either way we got banned and but it
added to the legends so you know we
weren't mad at it we understood it i
still watched saturday night live out of
course you can't be mad at it yeah [ __ ]
no
you know we're a part of the illustrious
[ __ ] ban list with rage against the
machine
sade and a few others you know on the
life ban list
there's gonna come a time where banning
people for weed and discriminating
against people for weed is gonna be a
[ __ ] cancelable thing for these
goddamn companies for sure well they got
they had weed sketches since then you
know big time now you know what i mean
so i would imagine if if people
made a thing about it maybe they lift
the ban but we don't give a [ __ ] i mean
we did it and if they were to let us get
back on
who knows maybe we'd do it right this
time yeah they lucked out that first
they got they lucked out because it was
gonna be something totally different
um but yeah that that's like moments
like that and then the other moment
that's sort of related to that is when
we're putting out our black sunday
record you know before we could rack
walk around anywhere and no one knew who
the [ __ ] we were especially because
we hadn't shown our faces on the cover
and things like that but
once um black sunday came out and
you know insane in the brain videos
popping all over mtv
couldn't go anywhere we you know i
remember going to the montebello mall
the first time in a long time that i
hadn't been there
and [ __ ]
it caused like a wave of [ __ ]
just to
swoop in on us and you know mall
security asked us to leave because damn
it was disturbing that [ __ ] piece
yeah and we left that never went back
because you're different it was
you know i mean so we went from being
like anonymous to now everybody knows
who the [ __ ] we are mtv too yeah so that
that was the that was the other
realization ultimate my privacy as a
private citizen is now gone i gotta
embrace this [ __ ] and not be
caught off guard and get mad because
this is what you asked for yeah
i mean if you if you want to be in this
business that's a part of it you should
pull the slip knot if you didn't want it
put the [ __ ] mask on yeah yeah you
know i it goes with the territory and
and i knew that so i never got bent
about it i was like all right well this
is what it is
[ __ ]
you know what be lucky because most
people will never experience this [ __ ]
in their life exactly just go go with it
that's i always trip on artists that
complain about that [ __ ] it's like hey
you should be mad if they ain't [ __ ]
with you
yes as long as people are still bugging
you yeah doing a good job man
yeah
also
probably the most legendary thing ever
though how did you guys get on the
[ __ ] simpsons
same thing you know
with with um crazy with saturday night
live i think you know
they they they sort of tap into
the pulse of culture at the time
and you know not for nothing but cyprus
hill we we tapped in at a time and
you know
was
some of the biggest
[ __ ] in hip-hop at its time at our peak
right and um
for sure why some of the biggest hip-hop
arena shows everyone oh yeah
we we sort of changed the game they
don't give us a lot of credit credit in
you know in terms of the books and media
and [ __ ] like that but those that no no
and and uh
with the simpsons they keep they're
they're on the pulse of everything they
are but i'm saying be so weed centric
right the simpsons would let you back
and it's not even it was like a 2018
video yeah this was a long time ago when
they did this episode and they run this
episode still you know and uh you know
so it for us it was like we were being
stamped like
the simpsons in snl
and being asked to that second that the
second woodstock i mean you know in
general the number two wood stock
for for me those three were the stat
right there you know that was like okay
we are
this yeah this is no longer are we this
no we are official this it's official
you know because they don't ask you
if if if you're not relevant to the
[ __ ] culture they definitely ain't
putting you on their [ __ ] it's so they
only put
things on that are very relevant to the
culture at the time yes
you know and uh so
it's it's it was a compliment and we
were like [ __ ] another thing that that's
it's forever another thing on the
checklist you know what i mean 100 years
that episode's still on the simpsons
yeah you know so we we were always like
we were thrilled about it like this
sentence oh hell yeah let's do it
yeah that's i just remember watching my
mom just trip because like i said my
whole life my mom just got a stack of
albums she'd take me to the shows this
before i ever did anything we well i
mean i'll sell them she didn't know it's
only but before i did any of the video
any of that [ __ ] so
for it to me to hear these stories now i
know my mom's watching right now so i'm
gonna hear this it's like [ __ ] from the
streets corner slanging rocks to doing
voiceovers on simpsons man that's some
[ __ ] i
never thought i was bumper sticker man
what i always wanted to know was in
eminem's heyday where he's coming at the
whole world
the only i always thought it was funny
the only rappers he ever just baked up
casually was be real was real
and uh he was doing [ __ ] with mugs and
[ __ ] like
how did was what was that like did you
have a relationship with him back in his
heyday you know
i love that dude like
just as a rapper he you know like
everybody always asks another rapper
what's your top
top five top three whatever and always
my top three is
krs one
eminem and jay-z those are my three
favorite rappers whatever of of
my top ten list right
um for different reasons or whatever but
eminem's always been somebody i
respected from day one just because he
came and flipped the game on its head
and in spite of his color
you know just showed
levels
that no one had ever reached in terms of
the skill set of of of
you know writing songs and rapping [ __ ]
and i always i always respected that
about him and he knew that that i was a
fan of his and and uh
we knew that he
was a fan of ours and stuff like that so
we just
always were cool with each other and we
shared management for a time
so you know there was
loosely a relationship there so it's not
like you were boys he was just showing
respect right you know
our our managers for some reason at the
time would sort of
keep distance from both squads so that
you know his squad breathed and we
breathed and all that stuff and as a
manager you've got to sort of juggle
and and and whatnot
but
for the most part the the interactions
that we did have with them and and uh
the relationship i have with them always
been cool and it's always been mutual
respect because he knows i respect his
get down he's one of my favorites and
you know i've always been a big
supporter of
um
m and d 12 in their whole [ __ ]
movement you know i mean so
um
he's always reciprocated with showing us
love and in places where we did not
expect because every shout out that we
ever got from from my dude
i never
expected it it just came hey did you
hear [ __ ] eminem just shouted you out
right now what
it was just a regular bar just as much
that's my [ __ ] right there
one of my favorite rappers he's shouting
me out all right my dude and um
it's it's everything to have
that kind of respect from people you
[ __ ] with yeah you know
i know we came before him and all that
but
as as what he's done and who he is and
what he means to the game i [ __ ]
respect the [ __ ] out of my dude and
i i would expect that he appreciates
that like i appreciate his love i mean
you know he don't have to [ __ ] shout
me out he's eminem
and so you know he could shout any
[ __ ] buddy in the world out and you
know
so i i always
probably registered that same like true
i don't give a [ __ ] out on stage like oh
yeah
yeah i mean we toured with m and 50 in
exhibit in europe on um
this thing called the anger management
tour
in europe so we got a chance to you know
be on the same stages
and you know fellowship you know like
that type of [ __ ] like you know
really you know be a team together
rocking this show and making each other
look good rather than everybody just
going for the head
trying to chop each other down like i
got we got the best show we're gonna
knock these here for hip hop yeah and
and uh you know so it was a fun time man
and and we made pretty dope connections
on that tour and
you know again em has always appreciated
us and we've always appreciated him so
he's always showing us love and
i mean to get it from
one that i consider one of the greatest
of all time you know that's awesome oh
yeah true statement
damn dude sorry um i know what time what
time we have marty i know it's been 140.
okay cool cool
um
before we get out of here
i remember there was a time when i was
about
14 15
and i had hitch from the bong just on
repeat on a cd when used to burn cds
yeah it was about three or four out of
the 15 songs
and that was enough time for me and my
friends to roll a blunt spark it argue
about who's gonna spark it and then
finish it that was my little routine
and i knew there was enough time
so i appreciate you being here because
now that i'm thinking about it just like
[ __ ] yeah it's just you know what i'm
saying yeah yeah
good [ __ ] and i appreciate you um you
know inviting me to the podcast and they
invited me to the spot it's a [ __ ]
great spot bro thank you you got to come
back and do the smoke box like we were
talking about
and then uh come back and do the green
thumb podcast and [ __ ] with us down
there we all love you down there we've
been waiting like when are we gonna get
this guy out let me know man let me know
we got to get you on bro we're we're
ready so yeah we'll make it happen
sooner than later [ __ ] yeah appreciate
it before you get out of here where can
um everybody find you at social media
wise just be real yeah instagram you
know it's just be real b-r-e-a-l with
the blue check you know it's real yeah
so you know it's real there's a lot of
fake profile
happening right now where they'll
duplicate your account and go try to
hustle people happens all day and your
name so blue check in there
and um
you know the dr greenthumb podcast we do
on youtube monday through friday catch
us there at 2 p.m pacific standard time
every day same same time same time yeah
so that you do live stream every day
live stream everyone except for weekends
so that means you can hop in the chat
talk to everybody that's right yeah it's
all about interaction right so we have
we have our you know the portion of the
show where we're having our conversation
and then in the last um
you know the last 45 minutes of the show
we open it up to the fans and you know
they either give shout outs make
requests they do some [ __ ] crazy
requests
and and they you know or they'll ask
questions right but some of the requests
right i'll give you an example right so
we have
we i
in broadcasting with a bunch of
individuals right
sometimes when people are are
you know excited they might talk over
each other and and sort of jumble all
that [ __ ] up but you know it's easier
for you because it's one on one right oh
i know but you know what it is to be in
a group setting and everybody's trying
to get their point in and not forget
their point especially if they're
stoners yeah that they can't hold it
they do it one-on-one i believe yes they
can't retain it so they got to say it
and it might be over what
right so
one day i i wanted the guys to hear what
this [ __ ] sounded like so i said listen
um we're gonna do this thing called the
moment of chaos and everybody was like
[ __ ] you mean a moment of chaos what the
[ __ ] is that
i said we're all gonna talk at the same
time
when you hear the explosion that's when
we stop
right but whatever is on your mind say
it randomly right here on the count of
three boom we start in everybody it
sounds like a room full of a hundred
[ __ ] people just talking at the same
time and then i hit the explosion boom
and it stopped
and we're like
did you hear what that sound like
yeah but it felt good
so so people started getting a kick out
of that moment and they request that
[ __ ] all the time it was it wasn't even
based off a request it was me trying to
teach these guys hey let's not talk at
the same time this [ __ ] sounds like this
yeah and the people got a kick out of
that so now they [ __ ] request it how
ironic yeah awesome yeah and then and
then some people will will do a moment
of ohms right
right the meditation ohms right because
remembering that that part um in the
cheech and chong movie the kids up in
smoke where they're in the car and
homeboy smoked the [ __ ] and he's she
just freaking out he's like chill out
man
yeah you can chill out and they they do
the whole
so we you know one day
it was a heated [ __ ] day so i did
that one
and that became a request like so when i
love this when everybody's off
yes the craziest [ __ ] like the the fans
key in off of these little things and
then they request them so it's a very
interactive show you know because eric
bobo and i is one of the co-hosts and
he's in the band with cypress hill he's
our percussion player um
you know we used to do these things um
called soldier stories before blogs or
vlogs existed
we were we were writing about every tour
and putting putting it up on our
original website which was
cypress hill online or something like
that back in the day and we would put
all of our soldier stories up
um you know day-to-day [ __ ] that we
would encounter on torches all the off
the hook stupid [ __ ] so that people
could laugh and whatever and then they
would make their comments it was
interactive [ __ ] right so
it was important for us to do this
platform and do these podcasts and make
it interactive so that
you know we could stay on that line of
always interacting with people because
that [ __ ] is important as an artist that
you know
when people feel like you're giving them
that time they feel more connected to
you so that's what that [ __ ] is all
about so those those requests of the
moments of chaos
crazy [ __ ] but it you you'll you'll
encounter it when you come to the show
trust it never not happens
never not
i mean
[ __ ] up requests but they're funny as
[ __ ]
you'll love it you got to come through
so every every monday through friday at
2 o'clock on youtube yeah monday through
friday 2 p.m pacific standard time on
youtube 7 easter i mean 5 eastern
um yeah man and we just we go live
and and uh
as anything happens
it's awesome i love that they have me
too man that sounds great actually
um and we smoke heavy i mean
i've watched some i've watched something
yeah i see you guys every single but
every single person's smoking their own
[ __ ] oh yeah and that's just a cloud and
then there's days where they might ask
for a request of the stunned and glass
flips you know what i mean where were
our boy cali blaze did 30 flips the
other day it was crazy what do you mean
like alpha ball yeah so we don't put
flour in it we use it with the with the
with the connect with the g pen connect
30 at once so we [ __ ] keep loading
the [ __ ] and we keep heating it so it's
just perpetual
so you're just loading it and heating it
up loading and heating well if you put
enough in there you just have to keep
heating it's like a [ __ ] keg stand
for yes
yes if you put enough you just keep
heating it you don't have to reload it
that's it and cali blaze if i could put
in a [ __ ] load the other day and he
ended up doing like 35 flips damn
yeah it's tough oh man now that you said
that people are going to be you better
[ __ ] try to do 30.
feel it already man
that's the 36 chamber who was talking
about mark that's exactly what it was
just me throwing up you guys
um
so hold on before sorry be uh it's be
real and everything with blue check yeah
before let me ask you a question
how do you not get your page just taken
away all the time i'm on my 25th page
it's it's crazy you asked that because i
remember when you tagged me on that like
me and tommy on these guys post weeds
these guys post weed and you don't
what's what's crazy is that
you know
my [ __ ]
has has been like
shadow band for a while like
they allow some of my posts to get run
they do it to you too yeah they do it to
me too
and then and then you know i i recently
looked in my violations because you know
there's two places to look for
violations
and one will say that you have zero and
nothing and blah blah blah don't even
send you a [ __ ] notification
but then you look in this other section
on your account status
right and it'll show you if someone
reported you for
harassment bullying or a violation on on
um if you were selling or or promoting
an illicit product like cannabis right
because
obviously it's not federally legal so
it's still
yes you know so if you
if you reposted something that was like
a flyer let's just say to one of our dr
green thumb event days and it says well
you know come to this event
the grand prizes are this and if you
mention what the grand prizes are and
those grand prizes are any cannabis
products
boom violation because
you're promoting that across the board
it's not regional to where
cannabis is legal it's you're promoting
across the board so you're in violation
they
you know they add that as a strike on
your account
so they don't tell people that and you
have to know where to find that [ __ ] so
that you could see how healthy
your account status is because they'll
tell you you're on the brink of losing
your [ __ ] or you're
you might possibly lose your [ __ ] or
your [ __ ] is in good standing and it has
that you just have to know where to look
for it and
yes and
and i wondered you know because i would
give people that hit me up
like yo how come i can't see your post
you unfollowed me you [ __ ] did this
i'm like i don't unfollow [ __ ]
unless they're talking some [ __ ]
right hateful
whatever um type [ __ ] you know but i
wasn't getting any of that so i'm like
what do you [ __ ] mean
i can't see your posts
you know unless i [ __ ] type your page
in it doesn't show up in my feed i'm
like
so i kept hearing [ __ ] like this and
some some
posts would [ __ ] go
and my posts that were like
you know [ __ ] related to my [ __ ] they
wouldn't necessarily go as much as i
knew they should especially with the
you know followers i have because
they're all organic i don't buy bots i
don't do none of that [ __ ]
and then i figured out how to find that
that that one part to show where your
account's at and it was in a different
place than where you you know they say
to look for your violations and [ __ ]
like that and i saw that three [ __ ]
accounts had reported me for bullying
right and it shows you what you said and
it shows you who violated you or who who
who um
who reported your account right and i
saw some [ __ ] and you know because i was
in this group and i'll make it quick
because i know we're you know getting
close
because i was in the group with the
prophets of rage
i would get
you know emails from [ __ ]
calling me communist and this and that
and the other oh because of raising a
machine going at me you know for for the
pr profits of rage which was derived
from rage against machine i get all this
hate [ __ ] from
you know right really far right wing
[ __ ] it you know thought you
know
because we were talking [ __ ] on trump
right so they'd hit me up and say this
[ __ ] to me and then i'd be like you
know what [ __ ] off blah blah blah this
that they take what i wrote to them that
was bullying and [ __ ] report me for
bullying when they came at me first and
i'm just sort of responding so they
baited me into that
[ __ ] and i got reported for three of
those right
and since then my [ __ ] had gotten shadow
banned in in certain posts and stuff
like that so i realized there's certain
[ __ ] i cannot post without them [ __ ]
putting the squash down they do it on
facebook too i mean this is i didn't
know it was happening to you too that's
insane that they do it [ __ ] this dude
of all people they do it to blue
checkers too yeah crazy man well i don't
i mean i don't tag companies i don't
show weed i don't show anything you know
that they just straight up deleted the
[ __ ] account i don't know my account
just i don't get nothing no violations
i'm just gone and i you know i shake the
[ __ ] and i'll [ __ ] send them reports
like what
what the [ __ ] you know because they
because they don't communicate nothing
to you and you and there's no response
center where that you can call and be
like hey man let's talk about my account
in these violations
because
th this you didn't get the whole
conversation you got what they sent you
how about that they threatened me and
said this that the other they don't give
a [ __ ] about that because they could
have some sort of infrastructure they
don't manage it in a smart way that was
better i feel though knowing that it's
not some guy that i maybe
didn't hook up one night in high school
and started to work at instagram goes
[ __ ] this guy thomas man no deleted it's
happening to a lot of us i remember that
it was happening to burner for a time
that was personal and and he went to he
went up there and spoke to the frisco
and
you know
he said that he kind of saw
some progress in his account
oh you know after he spoke with them up
there
but oh they don't care about me but they
don't give a [ __ ] hey trust they don't
give a [ __ ] about me neither i try to
tell you like you sign this application
get the [ __ ] out
they pick and choose what they're
they're gonna allow my [ __ ] to blow up
with oh they don't want you to make
money is what it is like anything that
can help you they want you to spend
money so if it's something that has
something to do with you they want you
to spend money to spend money to to to
um
to reach out beyond the 10
they deny me for all of that yeah so
they don't even allow me to do that
because they're there
because you're in violation
i'll show you where that that please of
the account
so one of my co-hosts e-zone right he's
been shadow band for a long time a lot
of my guys at b real tv are shadow ben
right
and
i was like let me see your phone bro let
me check this out right
this [ __ ] guy had like 12 violations
like he's like fit on the thinnest
lines
he you know he he had to create a backup
account so that he can just start so he
would go there and he's saying you know
he's getting more engagement there now
because that page is not shadow ben
right yeah and he knows what not to do
now
based off of what they flagged him for
on this and now seeing where it's
actually at because if you if you look
in the regular part it shows zero
violations and you're you thinking your
account is cool i just found out you
could do that yeah but you you go into
this other part where it says account
status
that's where you really find out where
your [ __ ] is pulls the [ __ ] off a few
times so maybe that's what's going on
dude that's exactly what's going on
people racism trolls trolls are smart
enough to know to bait you
i'm just gonna start thumbs up and all
the guys that are jerks i just thumbs up
bro i love you now now i just [ __ ]
block them whenever i see a [ __ ]
that's coming at me with some [ __ ]
because i used to engage them but now
that i know they're baiting us
i don't even do that [ __ ] i just block
them straight the [ __ ] up and if they
say something [ __ ] up i'm reporting
them first
what i mean because
because realistically because that you
know i was known for that like if you
said something
crazy or whatever i would [ __ ]
respond because oh no i love
it i love the [ __ ] back and forth
[ __ ] i like you know
all right on somebody you're gonna [ __ ]
on me i'm a [ __ ] back on you heavier
right
but now knowing that there's [ __ ] faces
trolling people like this you know and
and they're they can just edit what they
send as a report and not show their part
they you know what i mean so like if i
send you
some [ __ ] to say you know what when i
see you i'm gonna [ __ ] you up because
you're a piece of [ __ ] right
and then you respond to me like i dare
you [ __ ] [ __ ] you blah blah blah
i'll meet you someplace
they'll they'll
they'll screen capture what you said
not send any of what they said and be
like he's bullying me
that happened to me like three [ __ ]
times man
i was just
they don't have the time they don't have
the staff even though they're making all
that money they don't give a [ __ ] if
they don't get a smoke away they don't
give a [ __ ] until it's very illegal then
like oh the guy on the commercial learns
something it's good
for real
yeah i know you guys are going to be the
[ __ ] poster boys that's going to be
the most twisted irony is when they come
knocking like 23. we're starting
commercials category on [ __ ]
instagram do you guys mind can you
youtube it's a new it's a new column on
youtube
so yeah right the week 420 section like
i don't know if i have the time
let's see maybe one day
oh god all right well i know we're just
we're gonna sit here for hours and hours
so i'll i'll end it here thank you so
much for being here man right now
brother thanks for having me thank you
so much guys be real on all social
medias uh tuesday youtube that's dr
greenham podcast thank you so much man
thanks for having me appreciate it guys
this has been dope's usual podcast have
a dope day
nice i'm pretty high right now man
that last that last joint
perfect
[Music]
perfect
[Music]